Well,
today we turned to politics and the
structures of power under the early tutors
on the 22nd of August, 1485, uh,
Henry tutor who was then
the Earl of Richmond,
defeated and killed King Richard the
third at the battle of Bosworth field,
a battlefield,
which is located in central England
and the county of Leicestershire,
and was crowned upon the
battlefield with the crown,
which was found in the king's tent
and became king as Henry the seventh.
Now, in fact, his claim to the
throne was somewhat weak. Uh,
he was descended, uh, on
his father's side, uh,
from the widow of King Henry the fifth,
who had married Henry's
grandfather after the king's death.
Um, but that didn't establish
a direct claim to the throne.
His claim came principally through
his mother, lady Margaret Beaufort,
who was a descendant of the 14th
century King Edward. The third,
nevertheless,
week,
though his claim was Henry was the last
of the claimants of the Land Castilian
House.
And he took the throne on the
behalf of that particular group in,
uh, English politics,
which I'll explain later
in the 24 years following
his seizure of the throne.
He made it his business, first
of all to hang onto it. Uh,
secondly, to assert his authority
as best he could. And thirdly,
to pass on the crown to his son Henry
the eighth who succeeded him in 1,509 and
by doing so,
he founded a new dentisty,
the tutor dentisty.
Well today I want to look at some of
the early stages of that dynasty and in
particular to introduce the structures
of political power and authority as they
were exercised under Henry the seventh
and in the early part of the reign of
Henry the eighth.
And by doing so,
to show how they managed to establish
and consolidate the new regime.
Now by power,
of course I'm in that I'm concerned with
the capacity to secure compliance and
obedience on the part of others.
By authority,
I mean legitimate power,
those forms of power and it's
manifestations which were deemed by most,
if not all people to be legitimate,
to be binding,
to put you under obligation to obey.
There are many sources of such
power and authority, economic,
ideological, political,
military and so forth.
And to a considerable degree as we'll see,
they all overlapped and
reinforced one another,
but taken together,
they comprised the polity of the
time as contemporaries described it,
the polity, a system of
established government and rule.
Now,
in approaching this kind of subject,
it's currently fashionable
amongst political historians
of this period to speak
of the need for what they call
a new political history, uh,
as distinct from the old
constitutional history. Uh,
it's a central theme in John Guys Book,
the Tudor Monarchy from which several
of our key readings are taken.
By this people mean a political history,
which is less narrowly focused upon
the development of the institutions of
government.
That was for a long time the really
central concern of historians of this
period. They were very focused on the
development of particular institutions.
Instead,
now people are recommending a concern.
Instead with the changing context
and dynamics of political life and in
particular the social and
ideological context of politics?
Well, I'm very sympathetic
to that shift of perspective.
Uh, I can still remember
only too well, uh,
the old constitutional history
in its heyday as a student.
I sat sometimes at the feet of
the great professor Gr Elton,
who was famous for declaring that in
getting to grips with the structures of
government, it was essential that
students should learn to be bored.
And,
uh,
when he could deliver a whole lecture
on one of the seals used intuitive
government and the purposes for which
the seal was employed and so forth,
he was a man who sometimes
practiced what he preached.
But even if the approach has
changed somewhat over the years,
it's still essential that we do get to
grips with the institutions through which
government authority was exercised.
They provided the forum for political
competition and they shaped the way that
that political competition was conducted.
So historians today are very much
concerned with political culture.
I've offered a definition
of that on your handout,
but political culture involves also
institutions. They're part of it.
So we'll start by running over some
of the aspects of the institutional
structure under the early tutors and then
look at political society and then at
how political society could be animated
and controlled and the authority of
government sustained by the effective use
of all of these institutions under the
early.
Now the essential points about some of
these institutions are laid out on your
handout.
So I'll just click march through some
of them to briefly introduce them.
Right.
Well,
in 1500 England was already a very
old and by the standards of the day,
uh, quite intensively and
uniformly governed monarchy.
It had existed as a single monarchy
for six to 700 years already.
The origins of its high
degree of centralization
probably go back to the late
Saxon kings,
but in particular to the
time of the Norman Conquest
of the 11th century and its
consequences.
But that's not our business today.
Suffice to say that by 1500,
many of the central institutions of royal
government were very old and had been
established by the initiatives of medieval
kings and reflected the relationships
which they had hammered out over
time with their subjects above all,
with their most powerful subjects,
the nobility,
those who serve the king but could also
on occasion oppose him and had done so
many times in the past.
The king was of course at the
very center of the polity.
He was described by one 16th
century constitutional writer, uh,
so Thomas Smith as being the life,
the head and the authority of all things
that be done in this realm of England,
the principal functions of the king where
seem to be those of keeping the peace
and defending the realm,
maintaining the law and the administration
of Justice and upholding the church,
a relatively limited set of functions
compared to modern government.
And to achieve those ends.
The king enjoyed a variety of palace.
He enjoyed what were thought of as is
ordinary powers exercise within the
framework of the law.
But in time of emergency,
he might also exercise
residual absolute powers,
which could go beyond the
normal boundaries of the law.
Well,
English kings already had a very high
notion of their dignity and their
sovereign authority.
Um,
from the 14th century onwards there they
very often represented in the coinage.
Uh, they're represented wearing what's
known as the imperial crown. That's a,
a crown
which is enclosed at the top,
usually with a cross
and enclosed crown.
It was meant to symbolize the fact that
they recognized no authority higher than
themselves,
save God alone.
And though the authority of the pope
was exercise within the kingdom over the
church agreements which had been reached
and statutes which had been passed in
the 14th century, meant that in practice,
in making appointments and the church,
the pope usually acted on the advice.
And in consultation with the king,
they didn't override his authority.
So a monarchy of considerable dignity
claiming a sovereignty represented in the
imperial crown,
but high as the king's dignity was England
was also as one contemporary jurist.
John Fortescue put it,
uh, dominium political ed.
Regardless
the phrases there on your handout,
which meant that Royal
Authority was supreme.
That's the regardless part,
but it was also sustained and restrained
by certain political expectations.
Certain constitutional institutions.
First kings were expected to take advice.
They were expected to be guided by
council by the Council of the leading
subjects.
They ruled with the advice
of a variety of councils.
Occasionally a great council of the
leading nobility could be called,
especially when advice and support
was needed in the making of some major
decision.
Henry the seventh called such councils
have is leading nobleman on a number of
occasions,
more usually for day
to day administration.
The king was advised by a smaller council
which attended his person on a day to
day basis and handle the
executive business of government.
Some of its members were great,
no woman,
but very often their position in the
council was one which was largely on a
rubric.
They tended on the whole to profit
their advice to the king informally and
occasionally when they were in
attendance at court. For the most part.
For example,
Henry,
the seventh day to day council consisted
in its principal members not of the
great nobles of the Kingdom,
but have great members of the church.
Notably Cardinal John Morton,
who was one of his closest advisors
in the early stages of his rule,
and in addition,
a number of lawyers and
professional administrators,
those who are sometimes
described as men of business,
the nucleus of a kind
of royal bureaucracy.
So the king was expected to take counsel.
In addition,
he was restrained by the law.
The common law of England described as
common because it extended over the whole
realm.
The king's writ ran
everywhere in legal matters.
The common law had grown up over
centuries by custom and by precedent.
It was administered in the king's name
or legal writs began with the kings
title.
It was administered in his name,
though under normal circumstances,
he was expected to operate within
the constraints of the law,
the administration of the law,
the provision of justice,
and the redress of grievances.
The means of settling disputes peacefully
was one of the principal functions of
royal government.
Occasionally the king might
still sit himself in judgment.
One of the courts which became most
feared under Henry the seventh was the
king's Court of Star Chamber,
which met in a chamber of
the Palace of Westminster,
which happened to be decorated on the
roof with stars, the Star Chamber.
It was effectively the king's council
sitting as a law court and the king might
on occasion be personally present,
but for the most part the principal
law courts operated outside the royal
household.
They sat permanently in Westminster
in Westminster Hall that still stands
besides beside the houses of parliament
and they were staffed by role justices,
the names of the principal quarter.
On your handout,
there was a court of Kings bench, which
dealt principally with criminal matters,
the court of common pleas,
which dealt principally with civil cases
and the chancery the court of the Lord
Chancellor.
That court was a little unusual in
that it was not a common law court.
It was a court of Equity Equity.
That meant that in cases where the
common law didn't provide a remedy,
principles of natural justice might be
administered by the chancellor and for
that reason,
the chancellor was sometimes described
as being the conscience of the king could
provide a remedy based on natural
justice when the common law did not.
Okay.
In addition to the central courts,
the king also exercise
justice by commission.
Twice a year,
royal judges left West Westminster and
went out to ride to literally ride six
circuits going from county town to county
town where they heard cases arising,
civil cases and criminal cases
arising in the provinces.
Those were the assize courts,
the riding of circuits by royal justices,
and in addition,
the king exercise justice through the
commission of the piece in each county,
some leading gentlemen were appointed
justices of the peace commission to deal
with crimes,
usually petty crimes and other
administrative matters arising.
They met in a court called quarter
sessions because it met four times a year.
Yeah,
counsel and law came together in
another great institution that must be
mentioned. Parliament, the
periodic meeting of the king,
the nobility,
who had the right to sit in the House
of Lords and representatives of the
Commons of the kingdom.
The House of Lords consisted
of the leading lay and
church nobility of the realm
summoned by a personal writ to
attend in 15, 10. For example,
when parliament met, there
were 100 of them, 50 laymen,
50 great men of the church.
The House of Commons consisted of a
gathering of two representatives for each
county.
They were known as the knights of the
Shi'a and two representatives from each
city, which had the parliamentary
franchise. They were known as buttresses.
The city of London,
uh,
provided an exception if had
four members because of its size.
Now,
theoretically,
the members who came for the counties
were elected by free holders who had land
to the value of 40 shillings.
Though in fact,
contested elections were very rare.
Generally,
the elite of the counties
would get together in twos
from amongst their numbers
who would represent them.
They were selected rather than elected.
The urban franchise might
vary in some cities.
All householders had the vote in others.
The choice of a member for parliament was
restricted to a small oligarchy of the
leading citizens.
Parliament then represented the whole
realm and it had two great functions long
established.
First of all,
only parliament could
make statutes new laws,
which could override or
modify common law custom,
so the legislative sovereignty
of the realm lay in parliament.
We had the king,
the Lords and the Commons acted together.
Bill's proposing new laws were presented.
They were red and debated in each of the
houses before being passed and passed
onto the king for his consent or his veto.
Now,
if all that sounds rather familiar,
this is where it comes from.
Secondly,
parliament could grant taxes,
which from the 14th century required
the consent of the House of Commons.
It was essential that the Commons gave
their consent to any tax bill passing
through parliament.
Okay,
one last word on institutions
and that concerns finance.
The king was expected to live off his own.
That's the phrase they
use to live off his own.
That meant he was expected to live on
the revenues of the Royal Land Holdings.
The customs do use and other dues which
were due to him as feudal overlord of
the kingdom and for all normal purposes
that should provide for all his
expenses.
The collection and the disbursement
of royal revenues was handled by an
institution called the
Exchequer at Westminster
at least that was so in theory since
some late medieval kings took to handling
financial business in a more intimate
setting within their own household.
This was known as chamber finance because
they would deal with these matters in
the king's own lodgings or chamber.
Henry the seventh who was a notorious
workaholic and also extremely tight in
financial matters,
actually personally went over,
checked and initialed every page of the
chamber accounts to check his financial
situation.
Reliance on taxation was rare.
Taxes would be voted by parliament for
extraordinary circumstances and would
then be collected and returned to
the exchequer. So for the most part,
the king lives of his own.
Periodically taxes would be
granted for special reasons.
Okay.
That's a quick run through some of the
principal institutions of day to day
administration of royal government.
But of course,
administration is not
synonymous with government.
If you want to understand
the structures of power,
we need to look beyond this to the larger
political society within which these
institutions function or
sometimes failed to function.
Obviously the Monique stood at the
head of the structure of power.
This is still an age of personal monarchy
and the personalities of individual
Monnox colored and gave a particular
texture to particular reigns.
Henry the seventh.
It was a man who seems by all accounts
of him to have been of a cold,
somewhat detached,
calculative suspicious temperament.
His son Henry the eighth in
contrast, it was energetic, uh,
muscular vein, a mixture of large, yes,
on the one hand, uh, but prone to
bursts of terrifying wrath, uh,
on the other and the personalities of
different kings gave something of the
flavor to their range. Henry
the seventh. So for example,
it was only 28 when he won
the crown at boss with field.
It was only 52 when he died.
And yet it's been said,
we never think of him as a young man.
His personality was such that one
doesn't think of him that way.
In contrast to his flamboyant son,
the young Henry the eighth,
the various institutions of government
of course embodied the authority of the
Monique.
They gave stability and continuity,
but the actual exercise of power and
the maintenance of the authority of
government depended very much upon the
personality of the king and the way in
which the Kings interacted with
various important groups of people,
communities of interest within the realm.
By 1500, they're already existed. A,
a relatively broad political society which
was involved in government in one way
or another. Most ranks of society
down to the, the principal,
citizens of the towns or even the leaders
of village society were involved in
government in one way or another.
Uh,
except perhaps the very poor who were
described by Sir Thomas Smith as being
born to be ruled and not to rule others.
But of course if many people participated
in one way or another in the exercise
of royal power,
some people mattered a
great deal more than others.
And those who mattered most word,
of course,
the nobility and the gentry
and their counterparts,
the leaders of the church,
and the crucial relationship within the
whole structure of authority was that
between the king and his central officers
and those members of the social elites
who governed the localities,
it was those elites who constituted
deep political nation proper.
And when historians of this period
talk about the political nation,
it's primarily those people
they're talking about.
Okay.
Then our ability were absolutely
vital into very obvious ways,
which were interconnected.
First of all,
by virtue of their enormous
landed possessions,
they were the natural
rulers of the provinces.
Social Power and political
power in the realm intersected
the Percy family,
the earls of Northumberland
held absolutely vast lands
in the north of England
alongside the Scottish border where they
had the responsibility of defending the
border against the Scots.
Indeed, they still hold them. Uh,
the,
um,
they've virtually ruled that part of the
north from their principal castles at
Anik and walk with both of which still,
um,
if you've seen a Harry Potter
film, you've Seen Anna Cassell. Um,
it was used to shoot, uh,
parts of those movies.
The Percys were based there and it was
said with only a little exaggeration that
in that part of the kingdom
they knew no prince but a Percy.
Secondly,
the powers of Lordship which
were conferred by these
great estates translated
into military power.
The king had no standing army.
Henry the seventh was unusual in that
he had a small group of royal guards
permanently available,
the Yeoman of the guard.
Otherwise though there was no
standing army in time of war,
the king relied upon the nobility coming
in to support him with their armed
retainers and servants and each great
Lord had his affinity as it was called,
his affinity of retainers.
Men bound to his service by ties of
personal loyalty and often by formal
contract they wore his badge or his livery
and they were expected to follow him
when called upon people as humble as
farm tenants in some parts of the kingdom
still had to keep a horse and arms as
part of the conditions of holding their
farms from the gentry and nobility
in the north, for example.
That was commonly the case and when
called upon by the earls of Northumberland
or the earls of Westmoreland who
dominated what's now the lake district,
they would come in,
especially for service on the border.
To give one example of the importance of
the military power of nobility in 1536
at the outbreak of the rebellion against
the reformation known as the pilgrimage
of grace, the Earl of Sros, Bree,
who was based in the North Midlands was
able to mobilize no fewer than 3000 men
in only six days.
The rebellion had broken out in Yorkshire.
Sros was here.
The fact that he could mobilize 3000
men so quickly was absolutely crucial
because he was able to
move north and too hot.
The rebel advance to shadow the rebels
until a larger royal force could be
mustered.
In contrast to his friend
and former companion in arms,
Lord Darcy based in South Yorkshire,
sympathize with the
rebels and failed to move.
He sat on his hands for a while and
then eventually joined the rebels.
He should have been mustering
his troops to stop them.
That's why such men were crucial.
Darcy didn't act because he was out of
sympathy with royal policy in religion.
Shrosbree acted and say
today such men were vital.
Have you said all of this?
I must be careful not to exaggerate.
The nobility were rich and powerful,
but they didn't have fully independent
jurisdictions of their own where the
king's authority didn't run.
Some of the great nobility of continental
Europe enjoyed that kind of par.
So did some of those of Scotland
in this period in England.
Such jurisdictions had
existed in the past,
but they had mostly gradually fallen
into the crowns hand and been retained.
As a result,
English nobles depended ultimately for
their power upon grants of royal office.
Their local authority was
granted to them by the king
king ad with the fourth who
ruled between 1461 and 1483,
uh,
had ruled very largely by parceling
out spheres of influence to the great
nobility.
His system of government
has been described as being
somewhat like the mob in
the way that each of the great nobles
had his Quasar independent sphere of
influence,
but that was an anomalous situation.
For the most part.
The nobles depended upon Royal
Authority formally granted.
Nevertheless,
they still mattered a great deal.
Maintaining authority over
them was absolutely vital.
In the middle of the 15th century.
King Henry the sixth had failed
to do so leading first of all,
to rival and factionalism amongst his
nobles and eventually to a bid by one of
them,
the Duke of York,
to overthrow him because your cat arrival
claim to the throne that led to the on
and off civil wars,
which ran between 1450 and 1485 usually
described as the wars of the roses.
Okay.
Now,
the feuding
of the 15th century wars of the roses
had taken out a number of exceptionally
overmighty subjects amongst an ability,
but in the reign of Henry the seventh
there was still a dozen or so who really
mattered and not just in the
north or along the Welsh borders,
which were areas of insecurity,
but in the very heart of the kingdom
in East Anglia, the Dukes of Norfolk,
the Howard's were paramount in Kent Lord
Burger Veni was paramount in the west,
the Marquess of Exeter, the
Courtney family. What paramount.
Okay.
They still nurtured that
affinities of retainers.
They still enjoyed great prestige as
regional leaders and they still adhere to
an aristocratic code that
certainly stressed loyalty,
honor and service to king,
but nonetheless,
they could be very haughty,
very touchy.
They assumed their right to rule.
They assume they're right to be consulted
and they could be very dangerous
indeed if they were slighted.
No two of the king was
ever likely to forget that.
In 1485 at the battle of Bosworth,
the Stanley's William Stanley,
Lord Darby and his brother Thomas Stanley
brought their forces and then sat on
the hill waiting to see which way
the battle between the claimant,
Henry Tudor and King Richard.
The third would go when they decided
that it looked like today was gaining the
upper hand.
They joined in on his side
leading ultimately to the
death of Richard the third
and the desperate last charge
to try to break through.
That's what had happened on the
day that Henry came to the throne.
He was unlikely to forget that in
his dealings with his nobility.
So then how did the early tutors handle
their relationships with the various
institutions and groups on whom the
effectiveness of their rule dependent?
I think one can suggest four ways.
They did it by propaganda,
by patronage,
by consultation,
and when necessary by simple
coercion to ps two C's.
Propaganda, patronage,
consultation and coercion.
At this point in time, propaganda was
perhaps the least important of the four,
but it was not insignificant.
Great stress was laid in
royal proclamations and
ceremonial and symbolism upon
the divine nature of royal authority on
the fact that the king was ordained by
God and his subjects had a religious
duty of obedience and we the seventh was
very careful early in his reign to
obtain the recognition of the pope.
He further bolstered his claim to the
crown by marrying the daughter of his
predecessor, King Edward, the fourth
uniting the houses of Lancaster and York.
Through that marriage,
adding to his legitimacy
from the reign of Henry the
seventh onwards into the
reign of his son. The past.
The public memory of the past was to
some extent remodeled into an exaggerated
picture of the horrors which had attended
the breakdown of royal authority in
the wars of the roses.
They elaborated the myth of Richard the
third as a kind of monster king. I mean,
true enough. He was no sweetie,
but he was not the cookie monster,
uh, portrayed. For example, in
Shakespeare's history plays, uh,
historians were commissioned to write
appropriate histories celebrating the
Tudor Dynasty.
Polydore Virgin Italian humanists was
brought in to write one history in Latin.
Edward Hall produced another history
in England and titled the Union of the
illustrious families
of Lancaster and York,
which sustained the tutors
claim to the throne.
Shakespeare's history plays of course,
reflect very much this tutor
interpretation of history.
The image of royalty was cultivated
in a kind of theater of majesty,
tight as he was with his finances.
Henry the seventh,
never forgot the importance of having
a magnificent court and sumptuous
clothing. The pageantry of
the court was magnificent.
Great tournaments were held,
great buildings were erected,
perhaps the greatest of which Henry the
Seventh Chapel at Westminster Abbey,
where he's buried.
I'm still stands today.
Under the reign of Henry
the eighth portraiture,
royal portraiture began to emerge
as a means of royal propaganda.
Um, Henry, the eighth doll was,
had himself represented as something
more than human in the national portrait
gallery in London.
You can see the cartoon which survives
of a great painting of Henry and the to
the line, which was once on
the walls of his palace, uh,
of Whitehall.
Um,
Henry himself is shown much larger than
life size dwarfing or those around him.
Uh,
he was indeed a big man,
but he's represented as
even larger than life. Um,
you're probably familiar with the
Holbein portraits of Henry, you know,
standing arms on hips,
Mac gigantic shoulders,
pat it out with his doublet.
Um,
that kind of image of the king is the
one that dominates our memory and it was
meant to dominate those
who saw his portraits.
It's an image.
It's so familiar to people in England
was actually used to sell potato chips.
Um, a few years ago there was a, uh,
a brand of potato chips. Uh, they
know locked. They're no longer sell.
So this is not product placement,
uh, called tutor crisps.
We called crisps in England.
Henry the eighth on the packet glowering
out as you had your potato chips.
Of course he was a king,
known for his heart and eating
the Nobels themselves of course,
imitated all of this,
the theater of the great extended to them.
Take a look in the Yale Gallery of
British art where you'll see some of where
we'll go there later in the term to
look at some of the power portraits as
they're called,
the calm,
proud faces of these people
staring down from the walls.
Well, the main impact of portraiture and
so forth was on the members of the elite
themselves. They were the ones who
are likely to see these paintings,
but for a larger audience
they were precessions.
They were riled progresses where the
king would travel around an area in a
magnificent procession staying
in the houses of his principles,
subjects that were royal entries to
the city's accompanied by great ritual
pageants,
display and everywhere the
royal badge was displayed.
Jen, interesting topic, the,
the politics of display,
the art and architecture of power and
great deals being written about it that
interests you. Um, I can
recommend some reading.
Well,
the most significant then propaganda
of this type and in fact vitally
significant was the use of patronage,
the exercise of what they
called good Lord ship
that involved the conferring
or insignificant subjects
of honors and Prestige
and material benefits in
return for their loyal service.
After all, the interests of the king
and his great subjects were not opposed.
The system ideally could be
utilized to the advantage of both.
And so from Henry the seventh onwards,
the tutors were careful to
build up their own affinity,
their own loyal retainers,
royal lands,
we're used to this end.
Those who had shown their loyalty
and who are trusted would be granted
stewardships of royal lands where
they would share in the profits,
favorable leases,
the constable ships of castles,
officers of profit,
and of course grants of local authority
which demonstrated the king's trust and
which conferred honor and power
within their localities of prominence.
Well, if this was not only to the
personal benefit of the individual noble,
but it also enabled such men to dispense
patronage themselves downwards to their
own clients and retainers,
it enabled them to maintain their own
affinities and enhanced their standing.
The Tudor kings had no objection to
building up powerful man of this kind,
so long as they were loyal.
But ideally patronage
should be spread around.
It should be dispensed judiciously in a
way that would maximize the community of
interest in obeying the crown.
Let's look now at consultation.
The royal court was the very
center of the patronage system.
Access to the king was vital and those
who can control access to the king.
We're in positions of real power
under the young Henry the eighth.
Um, the gentleman of the
Privy Chamber, his personal,
those who hunted and um,
uh,
engage in other sports with the king.
Um,
we're absolutely central figures
in gaining access to the king.
Um, a principal amongst them, the
groom of the stool and office,
which still exists in Henry's day.
The groom of the stool literally looked
after the king's chamber pot and brought
it for him when it was needed.
These were people in an excellent position
to drop names into the king's ear,
but the court was also vital to the
business of consultation more broadly.
Any person of significance was expected
to visit the court from time to time.
And when they were there,
the king could be quite approachable.
Henry the seventh was quite
famously approachable.
He led people pop into the Privy
Chamber where he conducted business.
Henry the eighth was famously affable,
something of a back slapping hearty
type when he was in a good mood.
Nobles in particular expected
that kind of personal access.
They're expected to be able to give
their counsel informally on matters of
concern. They weren't part
of the regular executive,
their main duties layout
in their countries,
but they did expect a visit for part of
the year and have that kind of personal
contact more broadly.
The regular executive council was a point
of contact with these members of the
political nation.
It received letters and dispatch them.
It expressed the king's gracious
stanks for good service.
It handled all kinds of business
brought to its attention.
And then of course there was parliament,
the greatest occasion of consultation,
the whole political nation
gathered in common action.
So Thomas Smith said that every
Englishman is intended to be there present
either in person or by attorney from
the prince to the lowest person,
and the consent of the parliament
is taken to be every man's consent.
The king,
however,
only called parliament when he
needed money or new laws or support.
Before 1529 the early tutors
called it only occasionally,
but then from 1529 to 1559 in
the crisis of the reformation,
there were only eight years without
a parliamentary session and it grew
insignificance as a regular
part of the political process.
The Tudor kings usually got what
they wanted from parliament,
but they did it by managing it carefully.
It's compliance could never be simply
taken for granted. It had to be managed,
and it was a genuine form of debate.
The speaker of the House of Commons who
control the agenda was granted at the
beginning of each session the liberty
of free speech so that he could speak
openly to the king.
And by 1547 that liberty had been extended
to every member of parliament within
the precincts of the
meetings of parliament.
They could address any issue openly
for the good of the Prince and the
Commonwealth. And these members in
their turn got what they wanted.
Government bills might be amended in
the light of their local experience,
and a great deal of private legislation
intended for particular localities was
passed.
So parliament as a place of consultation
was a very significant forum for the
resolution of potential conflict for
the presenting of royal policy and its
explanation and justification.
The tutors used it very
carefully to achieve their
ends. In fact, on one occasion,
Henry the eighth flattered it by saying
that his royal dignity was never so high
as when he met with parliament
and the growing significance of this
institution is indicated by the anxiety of
members of the governing
elite to serve as members.
But finally,
if propaganda,
the use of patronage and consultation
didn't succeed in welding together the
interests of the crown and the political
nation there remained coercion.
What was described at the time as heavy
Lordship as distinct from good Lord
trip,
often evident under both Henry the
seventh and Henry the eighth as they
established their authority
and their dentisty
when necessary,
they would bring to parliament and
rushed through acts of attainder.
Acts of attainder simply declared
particular individuals guilty of treason
depriving them of their
lands and their status.
They were often used
against rebellious nobles.
They could be reversed in the interests
of the heirs to those estates if they
behaved themselves, but they had
to prove themselves compliant.
Henry the seventh made frequent
use of acts of attainder.
He very cleverly data the beginning of
his reign to the day before the battle of
Bosworth.
We've got parliament to agree to that.
That meant that everyone
who had opposed him,
even though they were actually fighting
for the person who was the king at the
time,
was automatically a traitor and
their lands were forfeit clever.
It enabled him to greatly extend the
royal lands in one move and there was more
of that to come acts of attainder where
also used against those who supported
pretenders to the throne who um,
were folk AI of um,
potential rebellions and actual rebellion
in 1487 against Henry the seventh
and we was the seventh was also willing
to use another coercive measure.
The placing of his and a bit of
nobility under Rick Cognizance,
Rick Cognizance bonds.
They were like a bail bond,
a bond illegal bond that nobles were
forced to enter into to be of good
behavior.
Or if they failed to pay
enormous financial penalties,
they usually had to find the sureties
from amongst their kinsmen and supporters
for those bonds,
which meant that those people had an
interest in making sure that the Nobel man
concerned,
complied and would lose out
themselves badly if he didn't.
These were used,
for example,
against any nobleman who in
any way infringed the um,
requirements of new laws.
For example,
under Henry the seventh retaining the
retaining of an affinity of clients was a
regulated by license only.
Those who are licensed to do so could
retain armed retainers and they were
forbidden from retaining any
member of the crown's own affinity.
You could owe loyalty to the king,
only anyone who infringed that was
likely to find himself hauled before the
council and faced with the
recognitions bond Lord Berg of any,
the principal magnet and Kent was put
under a potential fine of 70,000 pounds,
a massive sum of money for
such failure to comply.
It wasn't actually executed,
but it hung over his head like the sword
of Damocles anti complied in future.
And then there were the laws of treason.
In the 14th century,
the law of treason had been introduced
defining treason as acts against the
king's person or his family or open
rebellion against his authority.
Under the early tutors,
the law of treason was extended.
By the time of Henry the eight it came
to include even treasonable words,
such as, for example, denying
the legitimacy of the kings.
Many marriages,
particularly dangerous individuals,
were ruthlessly eliminated under Henry
the seventh the young Earl of Warwick,
Edward Earl of Warwick,
who was the last potential claimant
to the Yorkist claim to the throne,
was imprisoned in the Tower of London
from childhood where he was kept until
1499 when in a moment
of danger to the throne,
Henry the seventh had him executed.
So William Stanley,
one of those who had supported
Henry at the battle of Bosworth,
fell under the king suspicion and was
taken out in 1497 under the young Henry,
the eighth of presumptuous,
Edward Stafford drew Duke of Buckingham
was executed on trumped up charges in
1521 his real crime was that he
had a distant claim to the throne.
Henry didn't yet have a male heir and
it was alleged that Buckingham had
listened to prophecies that Henry never
would have a male heir and that he had
made some resentful
statements against the king.
When this came to the king's knowledge,
bucking homes, days were numbered
like most nobles who fell under royal
displeasure of Buckingham died by the ax.
Less a folk were hung,
drawn and quartered and less
honorable means of execution.
It meant that they were hung by the
neck until they were not quite dead.
Disemboweled their bowels burned before
their eyes and then cut down their
bodies cut into four quarters which
were dipped in pitch and send it to be
displayed at the gates of the
leading cities of the kingdom.
As an example to warn other potential
traitors and trial procedures in treason
trials could be extremely arbitrary.
The council could order a rest at will.
It could order the torture of suspects.
Torture wasn't normally
used in English law.
Defense counsel was denied.
Evidence could be fabricated to get
rid of unsuccessful losers in court.
Factional struggles the
very highest levels.
Then political conflict was
played out to the death,
especially under Henry the eighth indeed,
one historian of Henry the eight has
said that in some parts of his reign,
his court had the atmosphere
of the Kremlin under Stalin.
With people going in constant fear of
arousing the king's displeasure so the
crown could deliver large,
yes to the loyal.
It could consult with its leading subjects
but it could also brutally display
it's wrath.
The Majesty which had displayed on the
one hand was counterbalanced by terror.
All of this adds up then
to a political culture,
a set of institutions of
government animated by certain
understandings and rules
and practices which
govern political conduct.
That unwritten consensus about how
things were done was very well understood
throughout political society and political
stability depended upon sharing power
in varying degrees at various levels of
the structure in accordance with these
understandings.
Effective rule was the outcome of the
use of considerable political skills by
the kings and their advisors within
this framework to bring about willing
obedience and participation of their
leading subjects and for the most part the
early tutor kings proved
very able in achieving that,
in rebuilding the authority of the crown,
which had been so much shaken by the
civil wars of the 15th Century in
instilling habits of obedience in
reestablishing the latent power of the
monarchy and indeed in enhancing it.
Something that we'll discuss in section,
but finally change in government in the
16th century involved more than just
reasserting royal authority.
It also came to involve something else,
the expansion of the very scope
and objectives of government.
And to understand that we need to
see its development in the context of
processes of change,
which was scarcely on the agenda as
late as 1530 but which were very soon to
emerge.
And in the next few section lectures,
I'd be looking at those by examining
the most explosive of these new issues,
the issues of the succession
and the issue of religion.